it is freddie peralta on the mound for
milwaukee now the all-star for the
milwaukee brewers just got told last
night
and he strikes out
as freddie peralta gets into you to
start the ball game
this is blue back as second and out
there to make the play is peterson a one
two three first for peralta the brewers
are coming up
[Music]
on the bound vladimir gutierrez another
talented 25 year old right-hander
a little check swing grounder down the
third baseline suarez against the grain
the throw is going to pull the first
baseman bottle off the bag
and safe there is narvaez urriz takes
third first and third with two down abcl
garcia with 16 home runs so far
to right field and that's going to get
in for a base hit from third comes uras
headed to third it's an rbi single for
garcia and the brewers strike first on
top one to nothing
popped up
left side of the infield suarez
on the infield dirt little stagger but
he makes the catch and ends the inning a
run for the brewers on top one nothing
climb the ladder and strikes out neddy
quinn that strikeout number two for
peralta two down here in the second
inning
see where omar sets up now down and away
the pitch
down and away struck him out swinging
another accurate morgan's rock solid
strikeout for freddie peralta he goes
back to back with kays here in the
second
on the ground a third in the backhand of
suarez his throw across the diamond in
plenty of time
he's got a run in the bottom of the
first inning on top one to nothing
red spatting here in the third with
freeman at first and one away
and a bunt bid with two strikes and
he'll strike out
fourth strikeout for peralta two down
chopped left side and it's iris the
third baseman whose finger's going to
cross one in time to retire the side two
and a half done one-nothing milwaukee
2-2 pitch
swinging ground ball that's going to be
a base hit into left field he beats the
shift and yelich is on fastball on the
inner part of the plate kept his hands
inside
and shoots it past suarez
the o1
adamus ground ball hit the third could
be two suarez the second one on to first
it is a double play five four three they
go around the horn
60 for gutierrez
elevates it and teles hits a fly ball to
right field castellanos moves over and
makes the catcher wraps up the fourth
inning
and the pitch
swing and a one hopper hit to peterson
and he'll throw him out to end the
inning tell you what gutierrez hung in
there pretty well against peralta
so peralta's not allowed to hit through
the first five
sets up so many different options
fly ball headed to left where jesse
winker is
and he makes the catch we played five
it's one nothing milwaukee
[Music]
we're in the sixth inning freddy has
allowed nothing
left side you got the shift in play and
that is a damascus all he can do is run
it down that's the first hit as peralta
giving up that base hit in the infield
the shift was in play on the right side
and taking the other way is winker and
it's two on with nobody out nick
castellanos that's how tough this
situation gets right now
peralta all set again here it is
just off the outside freddy thought he
had the corner very close but low and
peralta frustrated again not getting
that low strike call
in the air to left field yell it's going
back towards the wall that ball is gone
a three-run home run for nick
castellanos his 18th of the year and
with one swing of the bat the reds take
a 3-1 lead
andy and winker getting on and castianos
hits a three-run shot for cincinnati
frustration for freddie peralta he
wanted that strikeout
pat murphy the bench coach will be the
acting manager for the rest of this one
because council
had some things to say and he was tossed
by gabe morales
three to one the reds have the lead over
the brewers brings up christian yelich
saying here's a bunt down the third
baseline and it's a good one the throw
is going to be wild
the ellich will stop right where he's at
let's hang him to see if he made a move
and he did wow
john libka first base umpire said he
made a baseball move to second base and
now he's gonna be ejected
back to back innings where he's seeing
the frustration of the brewers now he
goes down the line just that little bit
towards second base it was that last
little move that's enough wow
two down with narvaez at first tying run
at the plate for the brewers
[Applause]
as narvaez is headed for third and
beyond they're gonna try and score him
here
[Applause]
they do send him with two outs trying to
get him in and the relay is in time to
get him at the place
and that is strike three
chase peterson strikes out for the first
out of the seventh inning
swinging a miss and hira will strike out
back-to-back strikeouts for garrett
got away briefly from barnhart so he
applies the tag two down here in the
seventh inning
on the corner for strike three amir
garrett strikes out the side in order
three one rounds
runners in first and second with one out
that'll bring up joey votto
and did he go they will check yes he did
says doug eddings and bottom is furious
has been tossed
we've had the players ejected from both
sides in this one now the emotions
running high in this very important
series
on how one on this is tyrone taylor
batting for the first time
here it is
swinging a drive in the left deep
warning track get up get out of here go
for tyrone taylor
he just tied the game with a two-run
shot and the milwaukee brewers
come up with a great swing by taylor
swing and a miss and he comes in is able
to strike out peterson and end the
eighth inning
three three suarez to lead things off
joe for three in the game drives this
one to right field and deep back it goes
as garcia goes back gets up into the
upper deck hey eugenio suarez with his
18th home run of the year a blast off
josh hader and it puts the reds on top
four to three that ball was crushed
standing in milwaukee with two down in
the ninth inning
urea slips it fly ball
to left field winker is over
and under
to make the catch as the reds hold on
and win the cincinnati reds able to take
this game four to three is the final